From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Elna Baker, sitting in for Ira Glass. Kids have a stage where they learn to be embarrassed. It begins when they're toddlers, but some of us don't seem to take the lesson to heart, like my friend Jane Marie.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾尔娜·贝克，代班伊拉·格拉斯。孩子们在成长过程中会经历一个学习“尴尬”的阶段。这始于他们蹒跚学步时，但我们中的一些人似乎并没有把这门课放在心上，比如我的朋友简·玛丽。
I've known Jane for years. She used to work at the radio show. And her shamelessness was the quality I most admired about her, especially as a woman. You know, she didn't care what people thought. Am I acting nice? Am I dressed too sexy? Am I being loud? She didn't ask those questions. She was totally opinionated and scrappy.
我认识简很多年了。她曾在电台工作。她的厚脸皮是我最钦佩她的品质，尤其对于女性而言。你知道，她不在乎别人怎么想。我表现得够好吗？我穿得太性感了吗？我说话声音太大吗？她从不问这些问题。她非常有主见，也很有拼劲。
Jane was never embarrassed, and for a pretty specific reason. The way she grew up-- she was Methodist-- she was taught you are not the center of the universe, which made her feel free, like no one was watching.
简从不感到尴尬，这有个相当具体的原因。她的成长经历——她信奉卫理公会——教会她：你并不是宇宙的中心，这让她感到自由，仿佛没人注视着她。
To be embarrassed would be to assume that anyone in this room or anyone who witnessed this actually spends more than 5 seconds thinking about me. And they don't. Why would you think anyone but God gives a shit about anything you're doing, ever? They don't. Like, you are nothing. You mean nothing in the world. It's obnoxious, basically, to think that, like, any of your actions-- that anyone is actually looking in your direction.
感到尴尬就意味着假设在这个房间里的任何人，或者任何见证这一切的人，真的会花超过5秒钟的时间来关注我。而事实并非如此。你凭什么认为除了上帝之外，会有人在意你做的任何事，哪怕是一丁点？他们根本不在意。就像，你什么都不是。你在世界上毫无意义。认为自己的任何行为会被人盯着看，这简直是自作多情。
This worldview, that others weren't judging her, helped her not judge herself. Those thoughts just didn't occur to her.
这种世界观——即别人并没有在评判她——帮助她不去评判自己。那些念头根本就不会出现在她脑海里。
Did you have an inner critic?
你内心有批判的声音吗？
What do you mean by inner critic?
你指的内心批判是什么意思？
Like, a voice that--
就像，有一个声音会——
(LAUGHING) That's actually funny, sorry. I'm like, [KNOCK KNOCK], come again?
（笑）这真的很有趣，抱歉。我在想，[敲敲门]，你说什么？
So I was surprised when she texted me and said she'd heard I was looking for embarrassing stories to put on today's radio show. And that she had one, a big one that she'd never told anyone but her therapist, something that changed who she was. And I'll get to that story in about a minute.
所以当她给我发短信说听说我正在为今天的节目寻找尴尬故事时，我非常惊讶。她说她有一个，一个重大的故事，除了她的治疗师，她从未告诉过任何人，这件事改变了她。我一分钟后就会讲到那个故事。
But first, let me just say, I love embarrassing stories. I always ask for them at parties. If I hear a good one, I'll retell it for years. Some of them, so funny. But that's not the only reason I like them. I think the best ones say so much about us, reveal sides of ourselves maybe we'd rather not see.
但首先，我得说，我喜欢尴尬的故事。我总是在派对上讨要这些故事。如果听到一个好的，我会复述好几年。有些确实非常搞笑。但这并不是我喜欢它们的唯一原因。我认为最好的故事能体现我们的很多特质，揭示出我们内心深处可能不愿面对的一面。
And to prove the point that embarrassing stories have a lot to teach us, I decided to harness the power of the radio program. And we asked you for your embarrassing stories. People sent in over a thousand of them. Today we'll hear some of those and talk about what they reveal.
为了证明尴尬故事能教给我们很多东西，我决定利用电台节目的影响力。我们向你们征集了尴尬故事。人们寄来了超过一千个。今天我们将聆听其中的一些，并讨论它们揭示了什么。
But we're going to kick things off with Jane's story because, honestly, of the hundreds of embarrassing stories that I've heard, I've never heard another one like Jane's, where it changed someone so deeply. Her story is our first act. Let's call it Belle of the Gall.
但我们先从简的故事开始，因为老实说，在我听过的几百个尴尬故事里，我从没听过像简这样能让人发生如此深刻改变的故事。她的故事是我们节目的第一幕，我们称之为“尴尬女王”。
Jane's story starts at a big charity event at a bougie hotel in Beverly Hills. The night is a fundraiser for children with epilepsy. It's held in a grand ballroom with fine china and excessive centerpieces and some of the most powerful producers and executives in Hollywood.
简的故事开始于比弗利山庄一家高档酒店举行的大型慈善活动。那天晚上是为癫痫患儿举办的筹款晚会。现场布置在豪华宴会厅，用着精致的瓷器和华丽的餐桌花艺，座上宾包括好莱坞最有权势的制作人和高管。
This is not Jane's scene. She's there because she's interviewing for a job, a job with a big studio. A job that would be a major leap for her and pay a ton more money than she'd ever made.
这不属于简的世界。她出现在那儿是因为她在面试一份工作，一份大制片厂的工作。这份工作对她来说是一次重大飞跃，薪水远超她以往任何时候。
They'd met with her several times for interviews, and they'd invited her tonight and paid for her ticket as a kind of fun, looser, let's go do something more social and see how we all hit it off. Knowing where it's held and knowing it's a gala, Jane wears a ball gown, a two-piece dark green dress that shows off her midriff with a giant billowy skirt. She walks into the event and, to her surprise--
他们已经和她面试过好几次，邀请她今晚参加并支付了入场券，作为一种更轻松、更社交的方式，看看大家是否合拍。知道地点是晚宴，简穿了一件礼服，那是一件露出腰部的深绿色两件套裙装，裙摆宽大。她走进会场，惊讶地发现——
People were wearing, like, business casual instead of, like-- it wasn't black tie. And so I'm overdressed. They're passing around champagne flutes. I grab one but promise myself I'm only going to have half of this one glass of champagne before we sit down at the table. Like, I am going into this with full control of myself. Like, I am--
大家穿的都是商务休闲装，而不是——那不是黑领结晚宴。所以我穿得太隆重了。他们在那儿传着香槟。我拿了一杯，但答应自己坐下前只喝半杯。我本想完全控制住局面的，我想——
You're there to make a good impression.
你去那里是为了给人留下好印象。
I am there to make a great impression on these people. I want to work with them. And I want them to think I'm respectable. And it's a weird thing. Like, I hate that I still have to talk about the world this way. But when you're the only woman at the table, or one of two women at a table, and they're all, like, old, older white dudes, CEO types who, in a certain way, have your future in their hands. It doesn't feel great.
我是去给这些人留下深刻印象的。我想和他们共事。我想让他们觉得我很体面。这很奇怪。我讨厌自己仍得这样谈论这个世界。但当你是一桌人里唯一的女性，或者唯二的女性之一，而他们全都是年长的白人男性、CEO类型，且在某种程度上掌握着你的未来。那种感觉并不好。
In the ballroom of maybe 500 guests, they're seated at the main table, front and center. During dinner, Jane's looking for her opportunity to shine, a moment when they'll get to know her better. But it's not coming. The CEO guys are all talking over her. There's no moment to jump into the conversation. No one seems curious about her at all.
在大概有500位客人的宴会厅里，他们坐在最中心的席位。晚宴期间，简一直在寻找闪光的机会，一个能让他们更了解她的时刻。但机会一直没来。CEO们一直在抢话。根本没有机会插话。似乎没人对她表现出好奇。
So they get to the auction portion, or the fundraiser portion, of the evening. And there's a person up onstage who's calling the auction. And they say, all right, let's get things kicked off here.
接着来到了拍卖环节，或者说是筹款环节。台上的人正在主持拍卖。他们说，好的，让我们开始吧。
Jane has an idea. One time-- the only other time she's been to a gala-- they'd had an auction too. And to surprise her table, as a joke, when they started the bidding, before any of the celebrities that night-- Lady Gaga or Angela Bassett or Heidi Klum-- could get in a bid, Jane raised her paddle.
简有个主意。有一次——她唯一去过的另一次晚宴——也有拍卖环节。为了给同桌制造惊喜，开玩笑地，当竞拍刚开始，在所有明星——Lady Gaga、安吉拉·贝塞特或海蒂·克鲁姆——出价之前，简举起了牌子。
It was for an item that was tens of thousands of dollars. Jane was broke. Her friends at the table knew she couldn't afford it. But she figured, I'm surrounded by rich people. Someone will absolutely outbid me. And they did. The item went for hundreds of thousands of dollars. Everyone thought it was hilarious. So she looked at this table of CEOs and thinks--
那是件价值几万美元的拍品。简当时身无分文。同桌的朋友知道她买不起。但她心想，周围全是富人，肯定有人会出价更高。结果确实如此。那件拍品最终拍出了几十万美元。大家都觉得这很有趣。于是她看着这桌CEO，心想——
I know how to spice up the evening because I've done it before. I'm going to throw my paddle up again. I'm going to throw my paddle up again, get things cranking, have a funny story for our table to laugh about. And so they opened the bidding. And what I hear is, we're going to start the bidding out at $25,000.
我知道怎么炒热气氛，因为我以前干过。我要再次举牌。我要再次举牌，让气氛活跃起来，好让我们这桌有个笑话聊。于是他们开启了竞拍。我听到的是，起拍价是25000美元。
And I shoot my paddle up in the air with the same confidence that it'll get outbid immediately and then we're moving on. And then we're cooking with gas, and everybody's like, you're a blast, you know.
于是我带着同样的自信将牌子举到半空，心想马上就会有人出价更高，然后我们就能继续了。这样大家就会觉得我很风趣，你知道。
Jane feels a rush. Ha, that was fun. She waits to be outbid.
简感到一阵兴奋。哈哈，这真有趣。她等着别人出更高价。
And I had somehow not heard that this round of bidding was really just-- it wasn't something that anyone else could bid on.
而我当时完全没听出来，这一轮竞拍并不是——这不是其他人能出价的拍品。
It was not an auction at all. It was a pledge.
这根本不是拍卖，这是一个认捐环节。
So it was a $25,000 pledge from the eight people sitting at my table. It all happened really quickly. After I raised the paddle, they were like, yay. And they put the name of our table and everyone at our table up on this board. There was a TV screen, a large TV screen hanging from the ceiling, and the name of the company I was with and our table number and the amount of my pledge.
所以这是那一桌八个人要认捐25000美元。一切发生得太快了。我举牌后，他们欢呼起来。他们把我们桌的名号和每个人的名字都投到了大屏幕上。那是悬挂在天花板上的大屏幕，上面写着我所在公司的名称、我们的桌号以及我的认捐金额。
And I look over, and the one person I know best at the table, it looks like he's having hives, like an attack. Everyone else is just slack-jawed. Oh my god, Jane, what did you just do? What did you just do? What did you just do? And they're, like, mouthing this. Or even just saying it out loud, depending on how close they are to me. They all just stared at me and were like, how are you going to fix this for our table?
我转头看去，最熟悉的那个人看起来像是在起荨麻疹，像发作了一样。其他人全都目瞪口呆。天哪，简，你刚才干了什么？你干了什么？你干了什么？他们嘴里嘟囔着，或者直接说了出来，取决于他们离我有多近。他们全都盯着我，仿佛在问：你打算怎么帮我们桌收场？
Sometimes when something embarrassing happens to you, you exaggerate it in your head, think it's a bigger deal than it was. But in this case, no.
有时当你遇到尴尬的事，你会在脑海中夸大它，认为它比实际情况更严重。但这次，并不是。
I wish I could take this away from Jane and tell her her memory's wrong. Her memory's not wrong, because I'm here to tell you, yes, it was that bad. It really was. It was that bad. You're not making that up.
我真希望能替简分担，告诉她她的记忆出错了。但她的记忆没错，因为我可以告诉你，是的，情况就是那么糟。真的是那么糟。你没有编造。
That's Adam Davidson, Jane's only friend at the table. He's the guy who broke out into hives.
那位是亚当·戴维森，简同桌唯一的朋友。就是那个起荨麻疹的人。
As I'm remembering it, I just-- that feeling of wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah. The universe is different now. The universe is-- fix it, fix it. We're off course. [SIMULATED BUZZING] You know, like that kind of emergency.
如今回忆起来，那种感觉就像是瓦、瓦、瓦……宇宙秩序乱了。宇宙秩序——快修复，快修复。我们偏离轨道了。[模拟嗡嗡声]你知道，就是那种紧急状态。
Right. So part of the panic is like, if I don't stop this, I'm going to have to pay $25,000.
没错。所以恐慌的一部分在于：如果我不阻止这一切，我就得支付25000美元。
Uh, yeah, because I said I would. What if there's no way out of this and I have to, like, max out all my credit cards? No, I really was like, can you-- OK, because I don't have auction experience also, I'm like, can you take it back?
嗯，是的，因为我说我会付。如果没法脱身，我岂不是要刷爆所有信用卡？不，我当时真的在想，能不能——好吧，因为我也没参加过拍卖，我在想，能不能撤回？
She decides to try. At the other end of this giant ballroom, there's an exit. Jane thinks, there will be people in charge there. They can help me. So she bolts up out of her chair and heads there, fast as she can.
她决定试试。在巨大宴会厅的另一头有个出口。简想，那儿肯定有负责人。他们能帮我。于是她迅速起身，向那边跑去。
Through dozens of tables full of people, I mean, I really was having to be like, excuse me, pardon me, pardon me, excuse me, excuse me, pardon me, pardon me, excuse me. Like just, I gotta get out of here. So I get through the double doors at the back of the room as quickly as I can, and it slams shut behind me.
穿过几十张满是人的桌子，我当时真的不得不一边走一边说：借过，对不起，借过，借过，对不起……我得离开这儿。我迅速穿过后面的双开门，门在我身后“砰”地关上了。
"Who's running the auction?" she yells. A volunteer points her to a woman with a laptop. Jane rushes over and explains it's all a mistake. I don't have money. The woman is surprisingly understanding. She says, "What would you like to do?"
“谁在负责拍卖？”她大喊。一名志愿者指向一位正在用笔记本电脑的女士。简冲过去解释说一切都是误会。我没钱。那位女士出奇地善解人意。她说：“你想怎么做？”
What to do you want me to do? And I was like, well, I just need to, like, I take it back. I can't spend that money. And she was like, OK. And then bleep, bleep, blarp, she's in her computer. And I said, thank you, OK. And then I walk back into the ballroom and I'm looking up at the leaderboard, essentially, of all the pledges. And we're at the top. And then it disappears, right as I walk back in the room. It felt like a spotlight was turned on.
你想要我做什么？我说，好吧，我只是需要……我要撤回，我付不起那笔钱。她说，好的。然后噼里啪啦一顿操作，她在电脑上弄好了。我说，谢谢，好的。然后我走回宴会厅，抬头看那块认捐排行榜。我们原本在最上面，就在我走回房间的一瞬间，那个名字消失了。感觉就像聚光灯突然打在了我身上。
Like the whole room turned around to look at you.
就像整个房间的人都转过头来看你。
The whole room, it's record scratch. And everyone knows that I just took $25,000 away from this charity.
整个房间，就像唱片刮擦声响起。所有人都知道我刚刚从这个慈善机构撤走了25000美元。
But, of course, it wasn't Jane's name that was on the screen. It was the company's, the one she's hoping to work for.
但当然，屏幕上显示的不是简的名字。而是公司的名字，她原本希望去工作的那家公司。
So very quickly it wasn't, oh, Jane did this. It was, our table did this.
所以很快，大家想的就不是“简做了这事”，而是“我们那桌做了这事”。
Again, Jane's friend Adam.
又是简的朋友亚当。
And it wasn't like we went from first to second or first to third. We went from number 1 to, like, the bottom. So yeah, I was embarrassed. I think everyone at the table was embarrassed. Yes, we were embarrassed. Wouldn't you be embarrassed?
而且我们不是从第一名降到第二或第三。我们是从第一名直接掉到了榜底。所以是的，我感到很尴尬。我想同桌的每个人都很尴尬。是的，我们都很尴尬。换做是你，你不尴尬吗？
And so I get back to the table and I sit down and have kind of like a [FORCED LAUGH] "wasn't that"-- you know, like a nervous laugh. No one is enjoying that. And so I just start focusing on anything but the people around my table. I'm just really intently listening to the auctioneer guy. And we have to watch this really sad video that's, like, a mini-documentary about the children that we're supposed to be there to help. And they dim the lights.
所以我回到座位，坐下来，发出了那种[强颜欢笑]“那不是……”你知道，就是一种紧张的笑声。没人觉得有趣。于是我开始专注于除了同桌之外的任何事。我非常专心地听主持人的讲话。接着我们不得不看那段非常悲伤的视频，是一部关于我们本应去帮助的儿童的迷你纪录片。灯光暗了下来。
The movie is about 15 minutes long. The music is emotional. It's parents and their children with epilepsy talking about how scared and sad they feel, how much they need treatment. Sitting there in the dark watching this, this is the moment that hits Jane the hardest. It's not when everyone looks at her. It's when she realizes what she's actually done. She'd only thought of this evening as an opportunity for her to make an impression.
电影大约有15分钟长。音乐很煽情。画面中是患有癫痫的孩子和他们的父母，诉说着他们的恐惧和悲伤，以及他们是多么需要治疗。坐在黑暗中看着这一切，这是对简冲击最大的一刻。不是当每个人盯着她看的时候，而是当她意识到自己真正做了什么的时候。她一直把今晚视为自己表现的机会。
That was gross, what I did. It was gross and wrong. And watching these children with this illness, on a big screen, I was just like, I am the worst person on the Earth, that I bid and then I took it back, and then I said no. [SNIFFLE] There's was a part of me that was like, oh, could I just take out a few more credit cards or something?
我做的事真是太恶劣了。太恶劣而且错了。在大屏幕上看到这些患病的孩子，我当时想，我是世界上最糟糕的人，我竞拍了然后又撤回，我拒绝了。[抽泣] 有一部分我在想，我是不是可以多刷几张信用卡之类的？
And then it's like a tidal wave of what just happened and what I did and how mortifying it is. Just the layers of, like, the reasons I should be embarrassed and criticizing myself. You know, why would you even do that? Why would you do that? And then when you did do it, why would you try to get out of it?
然后就像一阵海啸袭来，想到刚刚发生的事，想到我做了什么，那种感觉太羞耻了。层层叠叠的、我应该感到尴尬和自我批评的理由。你知道，你为什么要那样做？你为什么要那样做？而且当你做了之后，为什么要试图逃避？
The answers to those questions are uncomfortable because they force Jane to see things about herself she doesn't like. Embarrassment can do that. It can show you your blind spot.
这些问题的答案让人不安，因为它们迫使简直视自己身上不喜欢的特质。尴尬能做到这一点。它能让你看到你的盲点。
It exposed a fatal flaw that I have to pay a lot of attention to now.
它暴露了我现在必须非常关注的一个致命弱点。
And what is that fatal flaw?
那个致命弱点是什么？
Um, hubris. Something about that made me feel like my confidence had bad consequences, that there was something bad about it.
嗯，狂妄自大。那件事中的某些东西让我觉得，我的自信带来了糟糕的后果，这其中有些不好的成分。
The night ends. She doesn't get the job. And she has it on pretty good authority that the decision boiled down to her big mistake that night. This stings, but that's not the crux of what that night did to her.
夜晚结束了。她没得到那份工作。她有相当可靠的消息来源确认，决定取决于她当晚犯下的那个大错。这很痛，但这并不是那个晚上带给她的核心影响。
It has actually changed a lot about how I act in public. I'm just much more self-conscious after that.
它确实改变了我很多在公共场合的行为方式。那之后我变得非常拘谨。
Really?
真的吗？
Like, I used to get super pumped about going to a party. And now that's kind of fraught. I know this is going to sound counterintuitive, but I've started leaving the house sometimes without makeup because it's like I don't want people thinking that I'm thinking about what they're thinking, if that makes sense. I don't want anyone to think I put makeup on for them. But this is just like the weirdest stuff that now pops into my head about what other people are thinking, where I wish I just didn't care.
比如，我以前去派对会特别兴奋。现在那变得有点让人忐忑。我知道这听起来很反直觉，但我现在开始有时不化妆就出门，因为我不想让别人觉得我在意他们的看法，如果这说得通的话。我不想让任何人觉得我是为他们而化妆。但这些奇怪的想法现在总是跳进我的脑海，关于别人在想什么，我真希望自己能不在乎。
I've always been that way, worrying what other people are thinking about me. And I can't imagine what it would be like to discover this as a full-on adult. Jane says everything feels different to her now.
我一直都是这样，担心别人怎么看我。我无法想象作为一个完全成熟的成年人发现这一点会是什么感觉。简说现在一切对她来说都不同了。
I feel completely neutered a lot of the time.
我常常觉得完全被阉割了一样。
Really?
真的？
Yeah, I do. I feel like it made me second guess myself a lot, I guess. I used to write essays about parenting and sex. And I would give advice and I would go on radio shows. And now I'm just like, shut up, Jane, shut up, Jane, shut up, Jane, shut up, Jane, shut up. No one is asking and no one wants to hear it.
是的，我确实这么觉得。我觉得那让我对自己产生了很多质疑。我以前写关于育儿和性的文章，我给出建议，我上电台节目。而现在我只是想：闭嘴吧简，闭嘴吧简，闭嘴吧简，没有人问你，也没人想听。
That's crazy to me that you can do something embarrassing once, and suddenly you have that inner policeman for the rest of your life. Is there anything that can make it go away, you think?
对我来说，因为一次尴尬就突然拥有了余生的“内心警察”，这太疯狂了。你认为有什么能让它消失吗？
I don't know. What could change it? I don't know. I just don't even have the desire. It's like, why would I want to change it, so that I could, like, put another ball gown on and go embarrass myself in front of a bunch of people? Like no, that doesn't sound fun. You know?
不知道。什么能改变它？不知道。我甚至都没那种渴望。就像，我为什么要改变它，好让我能再穿上礼服，在一堆人面前让自己尴尬一次？不，那听起来一点也不好玩，你知道吗？
It doesn't sound fun anymore. Like, I don't think that the lesson I learned was necessarily all bad. And honestly, when I think about the old version of me, it was kind of gross, in a way, you know? It's kind of obnoxious. It's like, that's a baby.
那听起来不再有趣了。而且老实说，我不认为我学到的教训全是坏事。坦白讲，当我想到过去的那个我，在某种程度上确实挺恶心的，你知道吗？挺令人讨厌的。就像个婴儿一样。
I'd honestly never thought of embarrassment as being helpful to anyone. It pummels us, humiliates us. But Jane's glad this happened to her. She's glad for her new, awful self-consciousness. She says her ego is smaller now, which means that with everyone in her life, she's quicker to admit when she's wrong and apologize. And overall, she says it's calmed her down. She observes more, hangs back, never wants to be the center of attention-- which, she says, is a lot less hectic.
老实说，我从未想过尴尬对任何人有帮助。它击垮我们，羞辱我们。但简很高兴这件事发生在自己身上。她很高兴自己有了新的、可怕的自觉性。她说她现在的自我意识变小了，这意味着生活中无论对谁，她都能更快地承认错误并道歉。总体而言，她说这让她冷静下来了。她观察得更多，不再冲在前面，再也不想成为关注的焦点——这让她觉得轻松多了。
Jane Marie is the host of the podcast The Dream.
简·玛丽是播客《梦想》的主持人。
Act 2, Judgment Day. Part of the reason I'm interested in embarrassment is because of this realization I had recently. I'm so embarrassed of myself all the time. At least once a day, I break out into a rash from embarrassment, like a couple of days ago when I learned from a coworker that all my life I've been mispronouncing the word "incongruous." See? I get embarrassed when I think people are looking at my eyebrows or when other people see my dog poop. Embarrassment is on me all the time, and I want to get it off.
第二幕，审判日。我对比尴尬感兴趣的部分原因，是因为我最近的一个发现。我总是对自己感到非常尴尬。至少每天一次，我会因为尴尬而起疹子，就像几天前，我从同事那里得知我这一生都把“incongruous”（不协调的）这个词念错了。你看？当我以为别人在看我的眉毛时，或者当别人看到我遛狗留下的粪便时，我都会感到尴尬。尴尬时刻伴随着我，我想要摆脱它。
And one of the ways my obsession with embarrassment has played out in the last few months is I'm in a group chat dedicated to it. There are four of us in it. One of the people, Kiese Laymon, I only met when we started this group. Any time we feel embarrassed or do something embarrassing, we write to each other.
过去几个月里，我对尴尬的痴迷以一种方式呈现出来：我加入了一个专门讨论尴尬的群聊。我们有四个人。其中一个人，基斯·莱蒙，是我加入这个群后才认识的。每当我们感到尴尬或做了尴尬的事，我们就会写给彼此。
It's how I know we've both worn Spanx for decades, or that he's self-conscious of his hairline or how he walks. These little secrets, you'd never know about someone otherwise. Sometimes we swap stories of past embarrassments, like the time Kiese was teaching a class at Vassar College on hip-hop as literature, and the alumni magazine wanted to do a story on him. This was back when he was in his 20s. They did the interview, and then a photographer comes to take his picture.
所以我才知道我们俩都已经穿了几十年的塑身衣了，或者他对于自己的发际线或走路姿势很在意。这些小秘密，否则你永远不会了解某人。有时我们会交换过去的尴尬故事，比如基斯在瓦萨学院教嘻哈文学课时，校友杂志想给他写篇报道。那还是在他20多岁的时候。采访做完了，摄影师来给他拍照。
So, we're in the library, and I'm like, where do you need me to stand? And they're like, well, could you crouch? And I was like, huh? I ain't never crouched for the photographs before. And they were like, you know, crouch and, like, do something cool with your hands. And I was like, what do you-- what do you want me to do?
我们在图书馆，我问：需要我站在哪里？他们说：嗯，你能蹲下来吗？我当时心想：啊？我以前拍照从来没蹲过。他们说：你知道，蹲下，然后用手摆出个酷酷的姿势。我问：你……你想要我做什么？
And then the lady says, could you do rap hands? And I'm just like, wait a minute now. You want me to do rap hands in a picture that's going to accompany an article about my teaching hip-hop as literature and hip-hop and literature? And you know my stupid ass did that shit? Like, I'm doing rap hands, fam. Like, I can't lie to you.
然后那位女士说：你能摆出“饶舌手势”吗？我当时想：等等。你想要我在一篇关于我教授嘻哈作为文学，以及嘻哈与文学的文章配图里，做“饶舌手势”？结果我这笨蛋真的做了那事？我真的摆出了饶舌手势，兄弟。我没法对你撒谎。
So then the fucking article comes out and my students, particularly my Black students, are like, bruh, you teach about representation, stereotypes, fetishization. There's nothing ironic about this picture. You look like a fucking fool, wannabe rapper/professor doing crouch rap hands.
结果该死的文章刊登了，我的学生，特别是黑人学生说：兄弟，你教的是代表性、刻板印象、恋物化。这张照片一点也不讽刺。你看起来像个彻头彻尾的傻瓜，一个想当饶舌歌手的教授在蹲着做饶舌手势。
I know so many of Kiese's day-to-day screw-ups from our embarrassment group. But it's funny. I never asked him an obvious question.
通过尴尬群，我知道了基斯很多日常的蠢事。但很有趣，我从未问过他一个显而易见的问题。
All right, so I guess-- I think-- you know, I'm coming into this totally blind, so I don't know what you're about to tell me. What's your most embarrassing story?
好的，那么我猜……我想……你知道，我对此一无所知，我不知道你要告诉我什么。你最尴尬的故事是什么？
My most embarrassing story has to do with Heavy. So I wrote this book called Heavy. I've been spending my entire life trying to write it. And I needed to write it to help my relationship with my mother and my relationship with my body. But also, it's a book that I wanted my grandmama to really be proud of.
我最尴尬的故事与《沉重》（Heavy）有关。我写了这本书叫《沉重》。我花了一辈子时间试图写它。我需要写它来改善我与母亲的关系，以及我与自己身体的关系。但同时，这也是一本我想让祖母真正为我骄傲的书。《纽约时报》将《沉重》列为过去50年最好的50本回忆录之一。书中大部分内容是关于基斯对他体重的羞耻感。他从319磅变得厌食，减到了159磅。然后又胖了回去，再减掉一些。通过暴露他与体重抗争的一切，他克服了它。在书的结尾，他写道：“我不再为这个沉重的黑人身体感到羞耻。”
The New York Times names Heavy one of the best 50 memoirs in the last 50 years. A lot of the book is about Kiese's shame around his weight. He went from being 319 pounds to anorexic, getting down to 159. Then gaining it back, then losing some. By exposing everything about his struggle with his weight, he overcomes it. Near the end of the book, he writes, "I am no longer ashamed of this heavy Black body."
（接上）他还谈到祖母对他有多重要。她很幽默，是他生命中的理性之声。她是唯一从不拿他的体重说事的人之一。在《沉重》中，他这样写祖母：“她负责任地爱我，从没伤害过我。”
Something else he talks about, how important his grandma is to him. She's funny, the voice of reason in his life. And she's one of the only people who's never on his case about his weight. In Heavy, he writes about his grandmother, "She responsibly loved me and never harmed me."
他让她失望过很多次——被大学开除，赌博输光了所有钱。但写这本书是他证明自己并非一无是处的方式，也是他试图完全解释自己。
He's disappointed her many times-- got kicked out of college, lost all his money to gambling. But writing this book was a way to prove to her he's not his failures. And it's his attempt to fully explain himself.
到书出版时，我想我已经赢得了许多我不曾预期会赢得的奖项。每次获奖，我都会想：哟，我奶奶一定会为我骄傲的。
By the time it comes out, I think I had won a lot of awards that I did not expect to win. And with every award, I just was like, yo, my granny is going to be proud of me.
书出版两个月后，他飞回密西西比州杰克逊市过圣诞节。这是他第一次有机会与全家人一起庆祝书的成功。他带了一摞书，每一本都签了献给家人的寄语。他带着大大的笑容跑进客厅。所有人都在那儿。他径直走向祖母，给了她一个大大的拥抱。
Two months after the book is published, he flies home to Jackson, Mississippi, for Christmas. It's the first chance he gets to celebrate the book's success with his whole family. And he brings a stack of books, each of which he's signed with a dedication to each family member. He runs into the living room with a big smile on his face. Everyone's there. He heads straight to his grandma and gives her a big hug.
她抬头看着我，然后看向我妈，说：这是基吗？然后她说：是啊，妈，这是基。我说：奶奶，你问我是不是我是什么意思？她直截了当地说：因为你太胖了，宝贝。你看起来胖得不像基了。她当着全家人的面说了这话。她当着我小表妹妮可的面说了。
She looks up at me, and then she looks over to my mom and she says, is this Kie? And then she's like, yeah, Mama, that's Kie. And I said, Grandmama, what you asking am I me for? And she just straight-up said, because you're so fat, baby. You look way too fat to be Kie. And she said it in front of my family. She said in front of my little cousin, Nicole.
我开始冒冷汗。我当时心想：搞什么鬼，搞什么鬼？我正在恐慌发作吗？当时，我不明白为什么。我没觉得是因为祖母叫我胖子而感到尴尬或羞耻导致的恐慌。
And I just started sweating. And I was like, what the fuck, what the fuck? Am I having a panic attack right now? And at the time, I didn't understand why. Like, I didn't think I was having a panic attack because of embarrassment or shame at my grandmother calling me fat.
这是一种羞辱、羞耻和尴尬的结合。羞耻和尴尬经常被混为一谈。但尴尬的独特性在于它总是与他人相关。你需要观众才能感到尴尬。
It was some combination of humiliation, shame, and embarrassment. Shame and embarrassment often get lumped together. But what makes embarrassment distinct is it's always tied to other people. You need an audience to be embarrassed.
就像，我可以独自在家里感到羞耻。
Like, I can be ashamed in my house by myself.
是的，绝对。
Yes, totally.
你知道我在说什么吗？我可以处在羞耻中，就像在羞耻的锅里煮。但尴尬对我来说更具戏剧性。我觉得，当你问我尴尬故事时，那全都是关于某人看到了我的故事。
You know what I'm saying? Like, I can be in shame, like, a boiling pot of shame. But embarrassment, to me, is much more dramatic. I feel like, when you ask me stories about embarrassment, they're all going to be stories about how somebody saw me.
因为如果我回到家，屋里除了奶奶没别人，她说了那话，会很受伤。我的意思是，那会伤人。但绝不会像她在全家人面前说出来那样伤害我。而且家人们都在表现出他们那种“向下看”的姿态。你知道，大家都听到了，但我们要假装没听到。
Because if I came in my house and there was nobody there but my Granny and she did that, it would hurt. I mean, it would hurt. But it would not come close to that hurt of having her say it in front of the entire family. And the family doing their version of looking down. You know, we're going to act like we didn't hear that, when everybody heard it.
所以我直接走出了屋子，钻进车里，努力调整呼吸。因为之前做过书的巡回宣传，我手里有阿普唑仑（Xanax），我用它在飞机上睡觉。[沉重的叹息] 我当时想：哟，我要不要吃半片阿普唑仑？到底是怎么回事？我不知道发生了什么。所以我没吃。我吃了阿普唑仑，然后又回到屋里，试着再来一次。
So I just walked right back out of the house, got in my car for a second, tried to get my breath right. And I had some Xanax because I was on book tour earlier, and I use Xanax to sleep on the planes. [HEAVY SIGH] So I was like, yo, should I take a half a Xanax? What the fuck is going on with me? I didn't know what was happening. So I didn't. I took the Xanax, one of the Xanax, and I went back in the house, tried to do it again.
回到奶奶身边。走进房间：奶奶，嘿，那个那个……基，孩子，我不知道你怎么变得这么胖，但你需要停止进食了。我觉得羞耻的部分在于：无论我写多少书，无论我把这些书写得有多好，但在我的家人，以及那个世界上对我最重要的人眼中，我看起来和感觉上不仅是胖，而且是恶心。
Went back to my Granny. Walked in the room, Granny, hey, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Kie, boy, I don't know how you got so fat, but you need to stop eating. And I think the shameful part was, like, I could write all the books in the world I wanted to. I could write one of those books as good as I could ever write them. But I was still going to look and feel not just fat, but gross, to my family.
你是否也觉得，在写书并竭尽全力去审视这些东西的过程中，你已经克服了那种对自己感到极度羞耻的能力？
Did you also feel like you had, in writing a book and working as hard as you possibly could to look at this stuff, that you had overcome the capacity to feel so ashamed of yourself?
是的。我以为，通过撰写身体、性、胖、性等内容，我已经做到了。我骗自己相信我已经从中解脱了。我想当我走进那个房间，以为《沉重》会保护我不受他们的批评，却遭到了那样的欢迎，还有祖母叫我胖子，看着我像在看一个胖子。当她看我时，除了一个中年大胖子她什么也看不到，那是氪石，是我的氪石。
Yes. I thought, in writing about, among other things, body and sex, fatness and sex, I did. I fooled myself into believing that I was delivered from it. And I think when I came in the room thinking Heavy would shield me from their critiques, and being greeted, initially, and then my grandmother calling me fat, looking at me like I'm fat. Not seeing anything but a fat ass middle-aged man when she looks at me is kryptonite, is my kryptonite.
她是唯一从不评判他的人。当他试图理解这种转变时，他能想到的唯一解释是：随着书的成功和带来的财富，她现在把他看作一个男人了。在她眼中，男人应该多产且精干。他在奶奶家待了几天，她不断提起这件事。好像基吃了基。他胖得像房子一样。他怎么胖成这样了？
She'd always been the one person who'd never judged him. And when he tries to make sense of this turnaround, the best he can come up with is, with the success of the book and the money it brought in, she now saw him as a man. And in her eyes, men were supposed to be productive and lean. He spends the next few days with his grandma, and she keeps bringing it up. It looks like Kie ate Kie. He's as big as a house. How did he get so fat?
我觉得这很尴尬，因为我天真地以为一本书能改变我的人生，让我不再在家人面前、不再在那个对我最重要的人面前看起来很胖。而那本书其实一点作用都没有。
And I just think that was embarrassing, to think that a book was going to change your life and make you not look and feel fat to your family and to the person who means the most in the world to you. And the book didn't matter at all.
噢，这真是摧毁性的。
Oh, it's crushing.
[笑] 噢，这真好笑。我不得不笑着讲完这一切。但是的，这感觉相当摧毁。
[LAUGHS] Oh, it's so funny. I have to laugh my way through all of that. But yeah, it felt pretty crushing.
但他平时并不会告诉人们这些事。老实说，当我请他讲最尴尬的故事时，我期待的是那种你在派对上讲的幽默故事。通常当人们开始讲这类故事时，他会讲出类似“饶舌手势”那样的内容。
But this isn't something he tells people in everyday conversation. Honestly, when I asked him for his most embarrassing story, I expected the kind of funny story you tell at a party. That's usually what he delivers when people start telling these kinds of stories, something more like Rap Hands.
那种尴尬和我奶奶家感受到的尴尬，在某种程度上，我甚至不知道它们是否该用同一个词来形容。因为我真的……我是说，我喜欢讲那个饶舌的故事。我从没讲过我告诉你关于奶奶的那个故事，因为我不喜欢回想那个。我讨厌讲它。你懂我的意思吗？
That embarrassment and the embarrassment I felt in my granny's house, in some way, I don't even know if they should be called the same word. Because I literally-- like, I like telling that story. I've never told the story I told you about my granny because I don't like remembering that. I don't like telling it. You know what I'm saying?
完全懂。我是说，有些事你可以一笑置之。但你无法笑对那些让你想死的事情。
Totally. I mean, because there's certain things that you can laugh at. But you can't laugh at the thing that makes you want to die.
是的，我是说我讲的尴尬故事往往不是真实的。故事的戏剧性可能是真的，但我会隐藏那个糊涂、有时带有毒性的核心，即认为讲尴尬故事会让人们更喜欢我。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, I mean the embarrassing stories that I tell are always not true. Like, the drama of the story will be true, but I'm going to hide that mushy, sometimes toxic center that thinks telling embarrassing stories will make people like me more. You know what I mean?
所以当我讲尴尬故事时，我没有讲的部分是：我要讲给你们听是因为我内心极度不自信，我想要让你们感觉什么或者发笑。所以如果我不讲那部分，我在讲故事时就是不诚实的。
So when I'm telling embarrassing stories, the part of the story I'm not telling is, I'm going to tell you all this story because I feel very fucking insecure and I want to make you feel or laugh. So if I'm not telling that part of the story, I'm being dishonest in the storytelling.
而且我们大多数人在讲这些自嘲故事时，都没有讲出那一面。我讲这个故事只是为了控制你们喜欢我的进度。我认为那些故事缺乏的就是这个。它们缺乏前奏。
And most of us aren't telling that part of the story when we tell these self-deprecating stories about whatever. I'm only telling you this story because I want to control the velocity and pace at which you like me. That's what I think those stories lack. They lack the preamble.
它们缺乏让你在第一时间需要讲一个搞笑故事的悲伤历史，他说。也许这有道理。谁会想在派对上提起那个？
They lack the sad history that makes you need to tell a funny story in the first place, he says. And maybe that makes sense. Who wants to bring that up at a party?
基斯·莱蒙是《沉重》和《长除法》的作者。接下来，一场以裸体告终的约会，但绝不是你可能想要的那种。一会儿回来，芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
Kiese Laymon is the author of Heavy and Long Division. Coming up, a date that ends in nudity, but absolutely not the kind that you might want. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾尔娜·贝克，代班伊拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“我的错”。今天我们来看看尴尬的故事以及它们揭示了什么。我们来到了第三幕，“创伤乐园”。就像我之前提到的，我们邀请听众分享你们最尴尬的故事。我们收到了数百条Facebook和Instagram留言，还有近一千封邮件。
It's This American Life. I'm Elna Baker, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, "My Bad." Today we're looking at embarrassing stories and what those reveal about us. We're at Act 3, Traumarama. Like I mentioned earlier, we asked you listeners to share your most embarrassing stories. We got hundreds of Facebook and Instagram messages and nearly a thousand emails.
好的，提醒一下，尴尬的故事有时涉及生理机能，我们有一两个类似的内容。如果这不是你喜欢的，别说我没提醒你。总之，这些寄来的故事，我请了本节目的常驻主持人伊拉·格拉斯来一起分享。
OK, quick note, embarrassing stories can sometimes involve bodily functions, and we have one or two like that. If that's not your thing, don't say I didn't warn you. Anyway, these stories you sent in, I invited the regular host of this show, Ira Glass, in to share those.
嘿，艾尔娜。
Hey, there, Elna.
嗨，伊拉。
Hi, Ira.
我能问你个问题吗？
So can I ask you something?
可以。
Yeah.
OK，你之前说你每天都会感到尴尬。真的吗？
OK, you said earlier that you get embarrassed every day. Really?
噢，当然。根据这个节目的录制进度，两天前我发生了一件非常尴尬的事。
Oh, yeah. I had something really embarrassing happen to me two nights ago, per this show.
是什么？
What was it?
从摔倒开始。我端着一盘披萨，结果绊倒了，披萨面朝下掉在沙发上。
It started with tripping and falling. I was carrying a pizza on a plate and I tripped, and it fell face-forward onto the couch.
嗯哼。这是在你家？
Uh-huh. This is in your own home?
不，是在我约会的那个男人的家里。那是张白沙发，所以会留下污渍。我正在清理它。然后发现了一块完美的马苏里拉芝士卷。你知道，它掉下来了，我不该吃的。但我还是想吃。所以我把它从沙发缝里捡出来，吃了。就在我咬下去的时候，我意识到——
No, this is at the guy I'm seeing, right. And it was, like, a white couch, so it stains. So I'm cleaning it up. And then there was a perfect piece of mozzarella curl. And, you know, it fell, so I shouldn't have eaten it. But I wanted to eat it. So I picked it up out of the-- it was stuck in the couch. I picked it up and ate it. And as I bit in, I realized--
[笑] 那不是——
[LAUGHS] It was not--
那是一个完整的脚趾甲，很大一个脚趾甲。
It was a full toenail, like, a big toe toenail.
（笑）什么？
(LAUGHING) What?
真是……
It was so--
那怎么会看起来像马苏里拉？马苏里拉是有立体感的。脚趾甲？
How does that look like mozzarella? Mozzarella has three dimensions to it. A toenail?
（笑）那是我做过最恶心的事。
(LAUGHING) It was the grossest thing I've ever done.
我觉得这不该怪你。那是他的错，他居然把脚趾甲留在沙发里。他才该感到尴尬。
I don't think that's on you. I think that that's on him for leaving the toenail in the couch. He should have been embarrassed.
是啊，但我把脚趾甲捡起来放进嘴里，这一系列事件发生的时机简直天衣无缝。
Yeah, but the needle that needed to be threaded for me to pick up a toenail and put it into my mouth, the sequence of events that would be the only reason I did that, happened seamlessly.
他在看吗？
And was he watching?
他在看。他也感到尴尬。他非常尴尬。
Yeah. He was embarrassed too. He was very embarrassed.
因为那是他的脚趾甲。
Because it was his toenail.
是的。他说：“这看起来不像我的。” 我说：“那除了你还能是谁的？”
Yeah. He goes, that just doesn't-- it just doesn't seem like me. I was like, well, whose toenail is it then?
是的，有闯入者进了你家，剪了指甲，什么都没偷，然后就走了。我在《纽约邮报》读到过，这种事经常发生。
Yeah, somebody broke into your apartment, cut their nails, didn't take anything, and left. I've been reading about that in the New York Post, happening all the time.
OK，但我们不是来讨论我的。我有这么多听众寄来的尴尬故事想和你分享。
OK, but we're not here to talk about me. We have all of these listener embarrassing stories I want to share with you.
是的，我很好奇你发现了什么。
Yes, and I am very curious about what you found.
好的，从这些邮件中我最突出的发现之一是，很多人写信说：“我肯定是世界上唯一一个会干这种事的人。” 但五封邮件过后，另一个人就在收件箱里发来了同样的故事。
All right, so one of the things that stood out to me most from reading all these emails is that so many people wrote in saying, I'm the only person who could have possibly done this. And then five emails later was someone in the inbox with the exact same story.
真的？
Really?
是的。比如有16个女性写了史诗级的生理期失败经历。
Yeah. Like, there were 16 women who wrote in with epic period fails.
不过我得说，那是可以预料到的。
Though I have to say, that's one you could kind of anticipate.
但你肯定预料不到有三个人错误地导致了拆弹小组出动。
Yeah, but you couldn't anticipate that three people were mistakenly the reason that a bomb squad got called in.
OK，是的，这确实想不到。
OK, yeah, didn't see that coming.
还有两个人盛装打扮去参加化妆舞会，结果发现搞错了日子，这也发生在我身上。
Or two people showed up dressed above and beyond to a costume party, only to find out that it was the wrong day, which also actually happened to me.
那是什么感觉？所以，我猜有几种不同的分类？
So what was that like? OK, so there are these, I guess, different categories of responses?
基本是这样，同样的事情一遍又一遍出现。
Yeah, basically, like, the same things came up over and over again.
OK，分类一下主要的。我想听听，第一名是什么？
OK, break down the big ones. I want to hear, what's the number one?
所以我想说最大的一个，第一名，是浴室故事。大概四分之一的人写了浴室的故事。接着是裸体故事。
So I would say the biggest one, the number one, was bathroom stories. Like, a quarter-- a quarter of the people who wrote us, bathroom stories. Followed by naked stories.
那是第二名。
That's number two.
第二名，别和“二号”搞混了。
Number two, not to be confused with number two.
我得说这两个都太基础了。
I will say that both of those are so basic.
我觉得人们感到尴尬的事情，都是小时候被告知“不要做”的事情。比如——
I think that people get embarrassed by the things that you were told not to do when you were a kid. Like--
不要裸体。
Don't be naked.
去洗手间。
Use the bathroom.
完全正确。
Exactly.
这些是最大的类别。剩下的又怎么分类呢？
And so those are the biggest categories. And then what do the rest break down into?
一些杂七杂八的小类。在暗恋对象面前出丑，有65个人写了这个。
Little kind of like various piles. There's embarrassing yourself in front of a crush. 65 people wrote in about that.
哇，65个人？
Wow, 65 people?
是的。或者在老板或名人面前出丑，79个人。
Yep. Or embarrassing yourself in front of your boss or a celebrity, 79 people.
嗯哼。我喜欢这两个被归在一起。继续。
Mm-hmm. I like that those two are lumped together. Keep going.
摔倒，通常是在重要场合。这有35个人。还有那些被揭穿谎言的人。
Tripping and falling, usually at an important event. That was 35 people. And then there were people who were caught in a lie.
好的，讲一个这种关于谎言被揭穿的吧。
All right, so tell me one like that, getting caught in a lie.
OK。有个叫威尔的人。他撒谎是有非常可以理解的原因的。在中学时，他因为是海地人而被无情霸凌。
OK. So there's this guy, Will. He told a lie for very understandable reasons. In middle school, he's ruthlessly bullied for being Haitian.
噢，天哪。
Oh, wow.
是的。那是艾滋病危机最严重的时候。我们国家甚至禁止海地人进入美国。
Yeah. And this is, like, during the height of the AIDS epidemic. Our country actually banned people from Haiti from entering the US.
因为艾滋病。
Because of AIDS.
没错。
Exactly.
对。
Right.
深夜电视节目里到处是关于海地人的笑话。所以在中学，威尔一直因为是海地人而被找麻烦。他被打，被嘲笑。
And there were jokes about Haitians on late night TV. And so, in middle school, Will is picked on all the time for being Haitian. He's beat up. He's teased.
所以我上高中了，九年级，新的一年，新的地点。离家很远。新的孩子，新的老师，九年级一切顺利。过了两个月，交了一些朋友。然后，有个孩子问我：“哟，你有口音，哪儿来的？” 我心想：噢，该死，又来了。
So boom, I go to high school, ninth grade, new year, new location. This is a location far away from my home. New kids, new teachers, ninth grade going well. Two months in, getting some friends. And then, one of the kids asked me, yo, you got an accent. Where you from? I'm like, oh, shit, here we go again.
所有的孩子都在等回应。我脱口而出：“哟，我是牙买加人。” 他们说：“噢，哇，牙买加人。” 我当时想：噢，该死，现在我余生都得当牙买加人了。我记得在和人交谈时，我会故意加入牙买加俚语，比如“哟，你做作业了吗？”之类的。只是为了维持这种牙买加形象。
And so there's all the kids waiting for a response. And I just remember, I'm like, yo, I'm Jamaican. And they was like, oh, whoa, yeah, mon, eh, bope, bope, bope. And I was like, oh shit, now I got to be Jamaican for the rest of my life. And I just remember, during my conversations with people, I would just throw in Jamaican phrases like, yo, did you do you homework, bope bope? Where you going? Yo, I didn't understand the lesson. Blood clot. You know, just saying that, just to keep up this Jamaican image.
听起来你甚至不太了解当牙买加人是怎么回事。
It sounds to me like you didn't even really know much about being Jamaican.
我什么都不了解……我了解的极少。我只知道他们的口音和音乐，我只是把刻板印象拿来用了，然后变成了那样。
I didn't know anything about being-- I knew very little about being Jamaican. I knew how they sounded from their music, but it was all just-- I took the stereotypes of Jamaicans and I became that.
所以他装了三年。
So he pulls this lie off for three years.
哇。
Wow.
是的。在学校里，他就是那个牙买加小孩。但后来，另一个牙买加小孩——真正的牙买加小孩——出现了，大家说：“噢，你得认识一下威尔。”
Yeah. At school, he's the Jamaican kid. But then, another Jamaican kid-- like, an actual Jamaican kid-- shows up and everyone's like, oh, you got to meet Will.
这对他就没好事了。
Oh, that's not good for him.
没错。
Nope.
然后他就开始盘问我。“哪儿来的？家里哪儿的？” 我全是在编。我当时在即兴发挥。然后他停下来，说：“那家伙不是牙买加人。” 我说：“噢，该死，该死。” 然后我说：“不，不，不。你是来自牙买加，我是来自牙买加……皇后区。”
And then he just started questioning me. Oh, where you from? Where your family from? And I'm just making stuff up. I was just freestyling it. Then he paused and said, that boy not Jamaican. And I was like, oh, shit, oh, shit. And I just said, no, no, no, no. You're from Jamaica. I'm from Jamaica, Queens.
我甚至不是来自皇后区的牙买加，我根本不是皇后区的。我来自布鲁克林，东纽约。
I'm not even from Jamaica, Queens. I'm not from Queens at all. I'm from Brooklyn, East New York.
OK，这是被揭穿谎言的人。再讲个类别。
OK, so that's people caught in a lie. Tell me another category.
好的，我特别喜欢那些试图避免尴尬结果反而让自己更尴尬的故事。
OK, so I especially love the category of embarrassing stories where people tried to avoid embarrassment. And in doing that, they embarrass themselves.
OK，让我听一个那样的。
OK, let me hear one like that.
OK，这件事发生在来自南卡罗来纳州默勒尔斯湾的玛丽·格雷女士身上。她是个伴娘，礼服寄到时发现太小了。婚礼当天，她劝说另一个穿大一号尺码的伴娘和她换礼服。礼服穿上了，但太紧了。于是她开始产生一种不理性的恐惧，觉得自己如果从礼服里挤出来会抢了新郎新娘的风头。
OK, so this happened to this lady, Mary Gray, from Murrells Inlet, South Carolina. So she's a bridesmaid whose dress arrives, and it's way too small. Day of the wedding, she convinces another bridesmaid, one size up, to swap dresses with her. This dress fits, but it's tight. And so she starts to get this irrational fear that if she's bulging out of her dress, she's going to upstage the bride and groom.
噢，就像人们会盯着她看而不是——
Oh, like people will look at her instead of--
没错。这绝对不行。然后她想到了一个主意：保鲜膜。
Exactly. This cannot happen. And then this idea hits her, Saran Wrap.
所以我走进厨房，找到保鲜膜。拿出来开始裹。我一圈又一圈地裹，直到把自己勒紧，礼服顺利拉上了拉链。我想：太棒了，这简直是个天才主意。然后我就出门了。
So I go into the kitchen. I find the Saran Wrap. I get it out and I just start wrapping. And I go around and around and around until I am cinched, and the dress zips up beautifully. And I think, yeah, this is going to work. This is actually genius. And out the door I go.
于是她在105华氏度的酷暑中站在祭坛前——
So she's standing in 105 degree heat at the altar--
没错，南卡罗来纳。
Right, South Carolina.
——站在新郎新娘旁边。台下有一大群人看着。她变得越来越热，越来越热。
--next to the bride and groom. And there's a big crowd watching. And she just starts getting hotter and hotter and hotter.
我能感觉到汗水开始顺着背流下来。我看着地板，眼前出现了光斑。我是容易昏倒的人，所以我知道那意味着什么。
I can feel the sweat starting to kind of roll down my back. And I'm looking down at the floor and I'm seeing spots. And I'm a fainter, so I know what that means.
所以，我尽可能隐蔽地转过身，请求旁边的伴郎帮我拉开拉链。当然，他完全不知道我在说什么。他说：“什么？” 我说：“我需要你拉开我的礼服拉链。” 于是他拉开了。现在所有人都知道我身上缠满了保鲜膜。
So, as subtly as possible, I turn around to my groomsman partner and I ask him to unzip my dress. And, of course, he has no idea what I'm talking about. And he's like, what? And I said, I need you to unzip my dress. So he does it. He unzips my dress. So now everyone knows that I'm wrapped up in Saran Wrap.
你当时羞耻坏了吗？
And are you just mortified?
我当时只是拼命想不要昏过去。所以我决定溜走。
I am just really focusing on not passing out. So I decide that I am going to take off.
她溜掉了。礼服敞开着。她错过了仪式剩下的部分，喝了点水。
She ducks away. Her dress is open. She misses the rest of the ceremony, gets some water.
这很有趣。她最大的恐惧是抢了新郎新娘的风头。结果她用了保鲜膜，反而导致她做了完全一样的事。她抢了新郎新娘的风头。
It's funny. Her greatest fear was that she was going to upstage the bride and groom. And so she does the Saran Wrap, and then that leads her to do exactly that. She upstages the bride and groom.
是的，是的。她是每个人对那场婚礼记忆最深的部分。
Yeah, yeah. She is the thing that everyone remembers about that wedding.
从头到尾，在这个故事里，我自己就是我最大的敌人。
From start to finish, I am my own worst enemy in this story.
OK，收件箱里最让人挥之不去的故事是这个。它太尴尬了，以至于发件人不想让我们用她的真名。
OK, so the most haunting story that came into our inbox was this one. And it's so embarrassing that the woman who sent it doesn't want us to use her real name.
OK。
OK.
我们叫她玛雅。玛雅去年参加了GRE考试，为了申请研究生。因为疫情，她必须在家里办公时线上考试。但这过程非常严格，为了防止作弊。有监考人员通过网络摄像头盯着她。
We're going to call her Maya. So Maya is taking the GRE this last year so she could apply to grad school. And because of COVID, she had to take it online in her home office. But it's like a very regimented process, just so they know they're not cheating. There's a proctor assigned to watch her through a webcam.
考试前，我得带他们参观一下我的考试区域。我得展示桌子底下、上面、墙壁，总之全部，确保我没作弊。我们做完了。一切就绪，我开始考试。
So before the test, I have to give them a little tour of my testing space. I have to show under the desk, over the desk, the walls, just everything so that they know I'm not cheating. So we do that. Everything is good to go. I start the test.
考到一半，她胃痛。她心想：噢，不。她必须得上厕所。而且现在就要去。她努力忍到了休息时间。但令她恐惧的是，下一次休息只有1分钟。她给监考发信息，问能不能离开一会儿再回来。对方告诉她——
So partway through the test, she has this pain in her stomach. And she's like, oh, no. She's got to go. And she's got to go now. So she manages to hold it until the break. But then, to her horror, the next break is just 1 minute long, right. So she messages the proctor and she's like, can I leave and come back in a minute? And he tells her--
如果你离开画面，你将失去考试资格。
If you leave the frame, you will forfeit the test.
[倒吸凉气]
[GASP]
我坐在那儿，心想：我不知道该怎么办。要么现在离开。放弃。去洗手间但不考GRE，放弃读研。要么做我实际做的那件事。
And so I'm sitting there, and I'm like, I don't know what to do. Either I leave now. I give up. I go to the bathroom and don't take the GRE, give up grad school. Or I do what I actually did.
她实际做的是在地上解决了。
What she actually does is she does the do on the floor.
等等，在镜头前，就像什么都没发生过一样？
Wait, while staying on camera, like nothing is happening at all?
没错。她把手臂放在椅子上支撑身体。
Exactly. She positions her arms on the chair.
别再描述这种心理画面了。我不想看。继续你的故事。
Stop with this mental image. I don't want to see it. Keep going with your story.
这居然成了一个独立的类别。我们听说其他四个人在标准化考试中也面临了同样的选择。
So this is surprisingly a category unto itself. We heard from four other people who had to make this same call during a standardized test.
什么？
What?
嗯哼。
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
也做了同样的决定？
And made the same decision?
是的。噢，他们尝试忍住但没成功。
Yeah. Oh, they tried to hold it and it didn't work for them.
后来呢？
So what happens?
她以为最糟糕的过去了。她撑到了下一次休息，有10分钟。她被允许离开房间。
So she assumes the worst of it is over. She makes it all the way to the next break. It's a 10-minute break. She's allowed to leave the room.
噢，在那次休息期间。
Oh, during that break.
是的。
Yeah.
但我很快意识到，10分钟休息结束后，我必须再次让他们检查考试区域，包括桌子底下。
But quickly, I realized that at the end of the 10-minute break I had to once again give them this web cam tour of my testing area, including under my desk.
噢，天哪，不。
Oh my god, no.
所以我意识到，OK，这10分钟休息意味着要清理干净。
So I realize, OK, the 10-minute break means cleaning this up.
记住，监考还在摄像头里看着她。所以她不得不像爬行一样爬过房间。
Keep in mind, the proctor is still watching her through her webcam. So she has to army crawl across the room on the floor.
噢，为了避开摄像头的视线。
Oh, to stay out of the camera's sight line.
没错，没错。
Exactly, exactly.
但你蒙混过关了，对吧？监考——
But you got away with it, right? Like, the proctor--
嗯——
Well--
——没看到，根本不知道。
--never saw, had no idea.
事情是这样的。我在Zoom上给朋友讲了这个故事。我就坐在我参加GRE考试的那张桌子前。我讲了故事，显然，我们都在笑什么的。然后一个朋友安静地等笑声平息，说：“你背后有个镜子吗？”
So here's the thing. I was telling this story to some friends over Zoom. And I'm sitting at the same desk where I took the GRE. And I told this story. And obviously, we're all laughing, whatever. And then one of my friends kind of like quietly waits for everything to die down and then says, is that a mirror behind you?
[倒吸凉气]
[GASP].
确实有。我背后有一个全尺寸的立式镜子。于是我回到房间门口，爬进去重演了所有动作。我只听到他们在笑。我甚至都不确定，我在想：你们到底是看到了还是没看到？他们当时笑得喘不过气来。所以最终有人说：“是的，绝对看得到。”
And it was. I have a full-sized standing mirror behind me. And so I went back to the door of the room and crawled all the way in and reenacted everything. And all I could hear was them laughing. I wasn't even sure. I was like, could you see it or not? Could you see it or not? But they, like, weren't breathing. And so, eventually, someone said, yeah, you could see everything, for sure.
她在这个故事里最深刻的感受是，这让她了解了关于自己的新信息。
So the thing that sticks out to her about this story is it showed her new information about herself.
新信息是——
The new information being--
比如，我愿意为了目标做出多卑劣的事。
Like, what lows she's willing to stoop to.
这太有意思了，因为我认为这是一个更积极的视角，反映了她为了得到想要的东西会付出多大的努力。
That's so interesting, because I think of it in a much more positive way of how far she'll go to get what she feels like she needs to get.
那根本不是她的感受。这就是这些尴尬故事的一个重点。人们大多数时候不会从积极的角度去想。
That is not her take on it at all. That's one of the big things with these embarrassing stories. People never take it the positive way, for the most part.
噢。
Oh.
他们总是会想：“我这一生都知道自己有点问题，现在我知道了。”
They always take it the way where they're like, I knew all my life something was wrong with me, and now I know.
现在，永远地，我读研的经历都被这段体验玷污了。让我无法释怀的是，这是我的选择。它不是发生在我身上的。这是我的选择。那会让它变得更好还是更糟？我不知道。
Now, forever more, me getting into grad school is tainted by this experience. The thing that I can't get over with this is that it was a choice I made. It didn't happen to me. It was a choice. Does that make it better or worse? I don't know.
我觉得这让它变得更糟。
I mean, I think it makes it worse.
（笑）我想也是。
(LAUGHING) I think so.
所以艾尔娜，你是超级对尴尬感兴趣的人。你思考了很多，也经历了很多。这一千个故事里，有什么是你以前不知道的吗？
So Elna, you're somebody who's super interested in embarrassment. Like, you've thought about it a lot. You've experienced it a lot. Is there something that going through a thousand of these stories showed you, that you didn't actually know before?
在这些邮件里，人们被这些错误折磨着。完全感到尴尬，并且常常终身背负。有时那只是很小的错误。读着它们，我心想：噢，其实问题在于我们认为自己不该犯错。我们认为自己必须在这一生中做到不犯错。而如果你说，好吧，在我这一生中，我会在公共场合摔倒，我的衣服会在不该露的时候露出来……你必须接受这是过程的一部分，是交易的一部分。
People in these emails, they were tortured by these mistakes. Totally embarrassed and often carried them their whole lives. And sometimes they were really small mistakes. And reading them, I feel like it just made me think, like, oh, actually, I think the problem is that we think we're not supposed to make mistakes. We think we're supposed to make it through this life without doing this, that, or the other. And if you just say, you know what, over the course of my lifetime, I'm going to trip and fall in public, my top is going to fly off when it's not supposed to. You just have to accept that that is part of it, that's part of the deal.
我喜欢你给节目带来的这个暖心的结局。
I like that you're bringing this to a heartwarming ending.
我知道你在挖苦我，但不用谢。
I know that you're being sarcastic, but you're welcome.
我想分享最后一个尴尬故事。第四幕，“把尴尬赤裸裸地呈现出来”。
I want to share one last embarrassing story. Act 4, Putting the Bare Ass in Embarrassing.
在你寄来的所有尴尬故事中，最常见的一种情况是你有点裸体，或者全身裸体，出现在公共场合。这是一个常见的恐惧。最频繁的噩梦之一就是在梦中低头发现自己在别人面前裸体。
Of all the kinds of embarrassing stories you sent in, one of the most common ones was a situation where you were a little bit naked or all the way naked, in public. This is a common fear. One of the most frequent nightmares is the dream where you look down and realize you're naked in front of other people.
弗洛伊德甚至在《梦的解析》中写过这一点。他称之为“裸露的尴尬梦”，引用说：“我相信我的绝大多数读者在梦中都曾处于过这种境地。” 当我们在清醒生活中感到尴尬时，我们经常会做这种梦。
Freud even wrote about it in The Interpretation of Dreams. He called it The Embarrassment Dream of Nakedness, and said, quote, "I believe that the great majority of my readers will at some time have found themselves in this situation in a dream." When we feel embarrassed in our waking life, we often have this dream.
下一位讲述者，来自纳什维尔，肯定做过这个梦。她叫卡里亚德。她个人对在公共场合裸体一点兴趣都没有。事实上，即使是泳装对她来说也是勉强。
The person in this next story, who wrote in from Nashville, has definitely had this dream. Her name is Cariad. She personally has no interest in being naked in public. In fact, even bathing suits are a stretch for her.
我觉得办泳池派对的人都是彻头彻尾的心理变态。我不明白为什么要那样做。你知道吗？我从小就这么想。幸运的是，英国没那么多这种派对。但我过去常来这里探望祖母，人们会举办泳池派对。我会问：为什么要这样？我现在还是这么想。
I think people who have pool parties are total psychopaths. I don't understand why you would do that. You know? I have since I was a kid. Luckily, there aren't a lot in England. But I used to come here to visit my grandmother, and people would throw pool parties. And I'd be like, why? And I still feel that way.
你为什么对我们所有人做这种事？
Why are you doing this to all of us?
是的，我才不想为了你的生日去什么该死的海滩。
Yeah, I don't want to go to the fucking beach for your goddamn birthday.
你马上要听到的故事发生于几年前，卡里亚德当时住在纽约市。她刚开始和一个她很喜欢的男人约会，一个急诊室医生，性格开朗，总是微笑，可靠。他讲了很多关于急诊室的有趣故事。我们叫他道格。
The story you're about to hear happened years ago, when Cariad was living in New York City. She had just started seeing this guy she liked a lot, an emergency room doctor, big personality, always smiling, reliable. He told a lot of funny stories about the ER. We're calling him Doug.
根据她的记忆，他们已经约会一个月左右了。他们曾在她家过夜，这是第一次在她家以外的地方过夜。当卡里亚德昏昏欲睡时——
The way she remembers it, they'd been seeing each other for about a month. They'd slept over at her place, and it's the first night she stays over at his. As Cariad is drifting off to sleep--
我只记得非常、非常累，非常想上厕所。那是我想睡着前的最后一个念头，心想：天呐，我真得去尿尿，但我懒得起床找厕所。然后我做了个梦，梦见我真的需要去厕所。我找啊找，到处都找不到。我推着一扇大金属门。那是锁着的。我过不去，我感到非常、非常沮丧。
I just remember being really, really tired and really needing to go to the bathroom. And that was kind of my last thought as I was falling to sleep was, ugh, I really need to pee, but I can't be bothered to get up and find the bathroom. And then I had this dream that I really needed to go to the bathroom. And I was looking for one and I couldn't find one anywhere. And I was pushing this big metal door, in my search for the bathroom. And it was locked. And I couldn't get through, and I was really, really frustrated.
然后，我醒了。我光着身子站在楼梯间，推着一扇从楼梯间通往公寓楼其他部分的门。
And then, I woke up. And I was naked, standing in a stairwell, pushing against a big door that went from the stairwell into the rest of the apartment building.
噢，天哪。
Oh my god.
感觉就像大脑融化了。这种情况完全不合逻辑。
It was like my mind melted. The logic of the situation made no sense.
卡里亚德梦游走出了道格的公寓。显然，她小时候有过几次这种情况，虽然她完全不记得了。而且她成年后从没梦游过。所以她没想到发生了什么。
Cariad had sleepwalked out of Doug's apartment. Apparently, she'd done this as a small child, just a few times, though she had no memory of it at all. And she'd never sleepwalked as an adult. So it didn't occur to her that that's what's happened.
我觉得自己彻底疯了。我就想：我怎么在这里？这怎么可能发生？我怎么醒着的？
I felt like I completely lost my mind. Like, just, how am I here? How is this a thing that is happening? How am I awake?
卡里亚德推开楼梯间的金属门，如释重负地看到走廊尽头是道格的公寓。她跑了过去。
Cariad pushes open the metal stairwell door and sees, to her relief, Doug's apartment at the end of the hall. She runs towards it.
然后我意识到，我不知道这到底是不是他的公寓。我转过身看，这就是纽约那种公寓楼，每层楼的公寓看起来都一模一样。我意识到我不能——
And then I realized, like, I don't know if this is his apartment. And I turned around and looked, and it was just one of those New York buildings, oh, just a bunch of apartments to each floor that all kind of looked the same. And I realized I can't--
这感觉像场噩梦。
This feels like a nightmare.
这是一场绝对的噩梦。
This was an absolute fucking nightmare.
卡里亚德靠近她认为是道格家门的公寓，虽然她不确定。
Cariad approaches the door she thinks his Doug's apartment, though she's not sure.
所以我决定敲敲门。然后在他们回应前，我跑回楼梯间。我把耳朵贴在门上。我把楼梯间的门打开一点缝以便听清。我看不见他们，他们也看不见我。这样如果声音是我认识的，我就能跑过去进公寓。如果是不认识的，他们就看不到我。希望他们能关上门。
So what I decide to do is knock on the door. And then I run away from the door, back into the stairwell, before they answer. And I put my ear to the door. I crack the door to the stairwell so I can hear them. But I can't see them, they can't see me. This way, if it's a voice I recognize, I can run around the corner and into the apartment. And if it's a voice I don't recognize, they won't see me. And hopefully they'll just close the door.
这计划相当聪明。
That's a pretty brilliant plan.
谢谢，谢谢。我照做了，那声音我不认识。我开始意识到我所处局势的恐怖程度。人们要起床去上班了，那发生时我不能在那儿。顺便说一句，我还是很想尿尿。我尿急到甚至因此醒来并梦游了。
Thank you, thank you. So I do that, and it is not a voice I recognize. And I start to realize the depth of the horror of the situation that I'm in. People are going to start getting up and going to work, and I cannot be there when that happens. By the way, I still really need to pee. Like, I need to pee so badly that it woke me up and made me sleepwalk, you know?
她决定光着身子尿尿最隐蔽的地方是楼梯间底部，靠着去大厅的门。如果有人想开门，她能顶回去。如果有人从楼梯下来，她能听到。所以她吞下尊严，真的那么做了。
She decides the least conspicuous place to pee while naked is at the bottom of the stairwell, leaning against the door to the lobby. If someone tries to open the door, she can push back. And if someone's coming down the stairs, she'll hear them. So she swallows her pride and does it.
我真是太恐怖了。我简直恐怖透了。我记得非常清楚自己坐在楼梯上哭。这种情况太荒谬了，我没法摆脱它。如果我当时多留意一下环境，就会知道他在2B室或者什么的。天呐，我在电梯里怎么就没留心呢？
I was just so horrified. I was so horrified. I remember very clearly just sitting down on this stairwell and just crying. This was just such a ridiculous situation that I couldn't get myself out of. And if only I had been more aware of my surroundings, I would have known that he was in apartment 2B, or whatever it was. Like, how could I have not paid attention in the lift?
我记得擦干眼泪，甚至没法用袖子擦鼻涕。我只能用手臂擦，心想：好吧，振作点。你必须掌控局面并解决它。你没得选。你必须解决它。所以我开始非常轻柔地尝试公寓楼所有的门。
And I remember drying my eyes and, like, I couldn't even wipe my nose on my sleeve. I'm wiping my nose on my arm and just thinking, all right, buck up. You have to take control of this situation and fix it. You do not have an option. You just have to fix it. And so I started very gently trying all of the doors in the apartment building.
她希望她出来的那个门还没锁。
Her hope is, whatever door she came out of will still be unlocked.
我系统地一层层试，每一个门都试了。在顶楼，有一户公寓能听到说话声。他们玩得很开心，听起来像是在开派对。
And I went systematically floor to floor and I tried every door. And on the top floor there was one apartment that I could hear voices in. And they were having a great time. It sounded like someone was having a party.
如果没别的办法，她想，我就敲这个门。但首先，她又试了所有的门。然后答案出现了——邮箱。他的名字会在邮箱上。她跑向一楼，透过门看到大厅全是玻璃窗。没有办法走到邮箱那边，而不被街上所有人看到她裸体。
If she can't find another solution, she thinks, I'm going to knock on this door. But first, she tries all the doors again. And then the answer occurs to her-- mailboxes. His name will be on his mailbox. She runs to the ground floor and sees through the door that the lobby is all glass windows. There's no way to get to the mailboxes without everyone in the street seeing her naked.
所以她又跑回顶楼那个派对，按了门铃，然后躲在门后。一个女人出来。显然喝醉了。卡里亚德叫住她，问能不能借口衣服，对方照做了。
So she heads back up to that party on the top floor, rings the bell, and then runs and hides behind the door. A woman comes out. She's clearly tipsy. Cariad calls to her, asking if she can come over to the stairwell, which the woman does.
你甚至怎么能遮住或藏住自己？
How are you even able to, like, cover or hide yourself?
我是说，真的没法……就像漫画里那样。一只手臂遮住胸部，小手像个无花果叶。在这种情况下，你只能这样。
I mean, there really is no-- it's just that cartoon. One arm across your boobs and your little hand is a fig leaf. I mean, that's all you can do in that situation.
卡里亚德解释了窘境并询问能否借件衣服。那个女人看起来完全没受影响。好像这种事经常发生一样。她示意卡里亚德进来然后走回派对。卡里亚德想：等等，不行，不不不。但门要关了，她只能勉强跟着进去。五个人在那儿。他们看到了她裸体。卡里亚德钻到沙发后面。女人给她拿了一件运动服。
Cariad explains her predicament and asks if she can borrow some clothes. The woman seems totally unfazed. Like, of course, this happens all the time. She gestures for Cariad to come on in and walks back into the party. Cariad's like, wait, no, no, no. But the door is closing, so she reluctantly follows. Five people are there. They see her naked. Cariad dives behind a couch. The woman brings her a tracksuit.
整个派对的人都动员起来帮卡里亚德解决这个情况。她向他们描述了道格。女人觉得她知道他住哪儿。他们敲了一两扇门，叫醒了并非他的邻居。他们给卡里亚德手机打电话，没人接。最终，女人让卡里亚德直接在沙发上睡。卡里亚德第二天早上7点醒来，再次拨打手机，终于接通了。
The whole party rallies to try and help Cariad solve this situation. She describes Doug to them. The woman thinks she knows where he lives. They knock on one or two doors, waking up neighbors who are not him. They call Cariad's cell, no answer. Eventually, the woman tells Cariad to just sleep on the couch. Cariad wakes up at 7:00 the next morning, tries her phone again, and gets an answer.
电话那头的人不是和我在一起的那个男人。是别人。而且他们很生气。他一直说：“你叫什么？你叫什么？” 我一直在说：“我要和那个男的说话。” 他们不肯把电话给他。
And the person on the phone is not the guy that I had been with. It's somebody else. And they're really angry. And he kept saying, what's your name, what's your name. And I kept saying, I want to speak to this guy. And they wouldn't hand the phone over.
我变得很生气，因为我在想：谁啊？把电话给他。他们说：“你叫什么名字？” 我说卡里亚德。然后他们说：“你姓什么？” 我说哈蒙。然后那男人接了电话。
And I was getting really pissed because I was like, well, who are you? Just give him the phone. And they said, what's your name, what's your name? And I said Cariad. And then they said, what's your last name? And I said Harmon. And then this guy gets on the phone.
她指的是道格。
She means Doug.
他只是说：“搞什么鬼？你们在哪儿……”他听起来很生气。
And he's just like, what the fuck? Where are-- he's, like, really angry.
原来，在卡里亚德光着身子在走廊跑的时候，他半夜醒来发现卡里亚德的衣服、钱包、手机都在，人却没了。就像消失了一样。
It turns out, while Cariad been running around the hallways naked, he'd woken up in the middle of the night to find Cariad's clothes, wallet, phone, but no Cariad. It was like she'd vanished.
我和道格谈过了。他不想上电台，但他说了这些。他到处找她。他看了室友房间，看她是不是不小心爬进了他们床上。然后他打开冰箱，又打开烤箱，然后才反应过来：她为什么会在烤箱里？
I talked to Doug. He didn't want to be on the radio, but here's what he said. He looked for her everywhere. He peeked into his roommate's room to see if maybe she'd accidentally crawled in their bed. Then he opened the fridge, then the oven, before catching himself and thinking, why would she be in the oven?
接下来，他搜了整栋楼，楼外。最终，他打了她朋友电话。他们不知道该怎么办。他想：她失踪太久了，还没穿衣服。这可能很严重。这时快天亮了，所以我们打了报警电话。警察20分钟后到了。他解释说：“我和这女孩出去的。她回到这，似乎迷路了。”
Next, he searched the building, outside the building. Eventually, he called one of her friends. They didn't know what to do. He thought, she's been gone long enough with no clothes on. This could be serious. By now, it was almost morning, so we called the police. They showed up 20 minutes later. He explained to them, I was out with this girl. She came back here. She appears to be lost.
其中一个警察开始咄咄逼人地盘问他。他不确定他们是不是就是混蛋，但他记得当时想他们可能是因为他是黑人而更怀疑他。情况瞬间升级。正如道格说的：“我记得当时感觉这是我处过最糟的情况。这家伙根本不信我说的是实话。也许他以为我杀了她。” 就在局势升级时，卡里亚德终于打通了电话。
One of the officers started questioning him aggressively. He's not certain if they were just jerks, but he remembers thinking they were probably more suspicious of him because he was Black. It went from 0 to 100 fast. As Doug put it, I remember feeling like this is the most screwed-up situation I've ever been in. This dude doesn't believe I'm telling the truth. Maybe he thinks I killed her. Just as things were escalating, Cariad finally got through on the phone.
卡里亚德乘电梯下到道格那层。当她走出时，警察迎上来。她意识到这就是接电话的人。解释清楚后，警察走了，只剩下卡里亚德和道格。
Cariad takes the elevator down to Doug's floor. When she steps out, the police greet her. She realizes this is who'd answered the phone. Once she explains her side of the story, they leave, and it's just Cariad and Doug.
我想我花了一分钟才认识到这对他的严重性。但我想一旦我真正意识到他在那一晚的某个时刻曾是一个嫌疑人——噢，他们根本没站在他那一边。
I think it took me a minute to recognize the gravity of what had happened to him. But I think once I really realized that at one point in the evening he was a suspect, like, oh, they were not on your side.
真有趣。这太像是白人会有的那种想法了。
That's funny. That's such a white person thing to think.
是的，是的，当然。你知道，在那一刻，我感受到了差距。我感受到了那一刻我们对彼此是多么不了解。但我记得我一直在说：“对不起，对不起。” 因为他确实很受惊。而他，作为一个可爱的人，只是说：“我……我很高兴你没事。但我得去过我的一天了。”
Yeah, yeah, of course. Of course it is, yeah. You know, I felt the gap. I felt how much we didn't really know each other, in that moment. But I just remember saying I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry. Because he was genuinely very shaken up. And he, being the lovely guy that he was, he was just like, I'm just-- I'm glad that you're OK. But I have to get on with my day.
他们再没约会过，不过主要是因为他几天后搬到了全国的另一边。这次约会本计划作为最后在一起的夜晚。但他们保持了联系。一年后，他回来探访，他和卡里亚德与他的朋友们去吃晚饭。
They never went out again, though mostly because he moved across the country a few days later. This date had been planned as kind of a last night together. But they stayed in touch. A year later, when he came back to visit, he and Cariad went to dinner with his friends.
身为绅士，我记得我们正在聊天，他说：“噢，我还没告诉他们那个故事。” 我说：“噢，没关系。如果你想讲，你可以讲。” 他说：“不不不不不。” 我想他是担心让我尴尬。
The gentleman that he is, I remember we were sort of chatting, and he said, oh, I haven't told them about the story. And I said, oh, it's fine. If you want to tell them, you could tell them. He said, no, no, no, no, no. I think he was worried about embarrassing me.
然后我去洗手间回来，大家都在哄笑。他看着我说：“我讲了。我讲了。我忍不住。” 我们都笑了。他还省略了那一部分，为了让故事好笑。
And then I went to the bathroom and I came back, and everybody was cracking up. And he looked at me and he said, I told them. I told them. I couldn't help it. And we all laughed about it. He also left that part out, in order for it to be funny.
既然事情最终结局还可以，他们现在在派对上都这么讲。他们省略了恐惧。
Since things came out OK in the end, they each tell it this way at parties. They leave out the fear.
所以，本周节目中我听到和收集到的大部分尴尬故事，当事人做了一些导致自己尴尬的事情。比如那位把保鲜膜裹在身上的女士。或者在拍卖会上举牌搞砸的人。
So, most of the embarrassing stories I've heard and collected for this week's show, the person does something that results in their embarrassment. Like, we have this lady, she Saran Wraps herself for a wedding. There's someone who raises a paddle in an auction and it goes awry.
所以我明白他们为什么感到尴尬。但你什么都没做。你没越界。你没犯错，但你依然感到尴尬。
And so, I get why they feel embarrassed. But you didn't do anything. You didn't overstep. You didn't make a mistake, but you still feel embarrassed.
是的。我想如果你从这事里去掉责任，也许那种尴尬的味道就少了一点。但它并没有消除尴尬。光着身子跑进一堆陌生人的房间里，这本身就是尴尬的。
Yeah. I suppose if you take blame off the table, it takes maybe a certain flavor of that embarrassment out. But it doesn't take the embarrassment away. There is something inherently embarrassing about running into a room full of people you don't know, naked.
就像，那件事确实发生在你身上。
Like, it still happened to you.
它确实发生了，是啊。我想我现在应该感到“防弹”了，不是吗？我想一旦发生了如此尴尬的事情，你会以某种方式跨过那个门槛。如果那都没事，那为什么还要感到尴尬？长久以来，我都在想：“卡里亚德，你让自己走出了那个困境。你不在下东区的楼梯间里赤身裸体。你能应付得了。”
It still happened to me, yeah. I suppose I should feel pretty bulletproof now, shouldn't I? I think once something really so embarrassing happens, I do think you sort of cross that threshold somehow. And if that's OK, then why be embarrassed? And for a long time, I would think, Cariad, you got yourself out of this situation. You're not naked in a stairwell on the Lower East Side. You can figure this out.
我喜欢节目在这个地方结束，不仅是因为那个人感到尴尬。她经历了一个如同尴尬隐喻的体验，一个我们大多数人只在噩梦中知晓的经历，并从中变得更好。我喜欢认为这正是尴尬所能做到的。
I like ending the show there, someone who wasn't just embarrassed. She lived the experience that's like a metaphor for embarrassment, an experience most of us only know from nightmares, and came out better for it. I like thinking that's what embarrassment can do.
今天的节目由我、托宾·洛和黛安·吴制作。参与节目制作的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、苏珊·伯顿、肖恩·科尔、安德里亚·洛佩兹·克鲁萨多、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、塞思·林德、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和克洛伊·韦纳。我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑戴维·克斯滕鲍姆，执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Our program was produced today by me, Tobin Low, and Diane Wu. The people who put our show together include Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alix Spiegel, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Chloee Weiner. Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman, senior editor, David Kestenbaum, our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
特别感谢今天所有写信分享最尴尬故事的听众们。还要感谢丽莎·波拉克、阿里·萨珀斯坦、亨利·菲利普斯、威尔·西尔万斯、癫痫基金会、凯文·艾利森、弗兰奇·弗伦奇、凯特和亚伦·安德森、里根·贝克、霍普·罗森布拉特、布莱恩·芬克尔斯坦、艾尔·比尔肯肯珀、艾玛莉·布兰顿、卡门·古巴和塔拉·韦斯特弗。
Special thanks today to all the listeners who wrote in with their most embarrassing stories. Also, thanks to Lisa Pollack, Ari Saperstein, Henry Phillips, Will Sylvance, The Epilepsy Foundation, Kevin Allison, Franqi French, Kate and Aaron Anderson, Reagan Baker, Hope Rosenblatt, Brian Finkelstein, Elle Birkenkemper, Emmali Branton, Carmen Cuba, and Tara Westover.
访问我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，你可以免费在线收听我们700多集的档案节目。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX负责分发至各公共广播电台。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
和往常一样，感谢我的老板伊拉·格拉斯。你知道，他告诉我他每个周六晚上都做同样的事。看阿姆的电影《8英里》，狂灌一罐大啤酒，对着镜子里的自己发呆。
Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. You know, he told me he does the same thing every Saturday night. He watches the Eminem movie, 8 Mile, shotguns a tall boy, stares at himself in the mirror.
然后我开始饶舌。
And I just start rapping.
我是艾尔娜·贝克。下周请继续收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Elna Baker. Join us next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是埃尔娜·贝克。下周请继续收听《美国生活》的更多故事。